today we're talking about recaptcha
self-service security analytics
autonomous vehicles and climate trace
i'm stephanie wong and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news
recaptcha enterprise is google's online
fraud detection service that leverages
over a decade of experience defending
the internet recaptcha enterprise can be
used to prevent fraud and attacks
perpetrated by scripts bot software or
humans as a part of our continued
investment here we're announcing account
defender in public preview it's a new
feature built into recaptcha enterprise
that helps you determine if an action
aligns or deviates from the account
owner's typical behavior
as more organizations embrace the
principles of autonomic security
operations we continue to research and
develop new initiatives that can
simplify the adoption of continuous
detection and continuous response
workflows for security operations teams
to this end we're excited to announce
community security analytics a set of
open source queries and rules designed
for self-service security analytics
designed to help detect common
cloud-based threats
as we continue to explore climate
solutions using machine learning in our
people and planet ai youtube series we
have been blown away by an amazing
project called climate trace it's a
collaborative data sharing effort across
50 plus organizations with the intention
of helping the public for free to view
where carbon pollution is emitted by
country and even by industry in a
meaningful and visual way as a web app
learn more and check out the video in
the blog
cruise has been focused on tackling city
driving since 2013 and with more than 3
million autonomous miles under our belt
we're getting closer to delivering an
all-electric shared self-driving service
in january 2022 we reached a major
milestone members of the public took
their very first fully driverless rides
in san francisco developing an urban
fleet of fully autonomous vehicles is an
incredible challenge to be successful we
needed to build both the av tech that's
out on the road and the ecosystem of
tools our engineers use internally check
out the blog for more
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud